i do
think though that
the more i have conversations with
people
where i would assume that they have
they would have a visceral reaction to
everything i
would say that don't i feel like
just the extremes on both sides of the
left and the right
i feel like they're it's such a small
pool but because they're the loudest
they are like almost the brand
ambassadors for that side and everyone
thinks that they represent
what um the other side is and i think
when it comes down to it every i think
everyone wants
a decent interaction with everybody and
everyone's wanting to put the weapons
down but they just don't know are you
really going to
drop your weapon though and not pick it
up
and i think that's why we carry around
the weapon
because we have a paranoia are you going
to use it on me
i won't use it on you but i need it just
in case you do
but i think everyone's exhausted i think
everyone wants
i think most people are the mo the most
the more i talk and interact with people
and i say this in the sense of
i'll talk to someone that figuratively
has the weapon like ready to swing
and the more we talk the more they're
just like
they don't want to hold it like it's
heavy that's how i
that's my and i can't say like my all my
and my anecdotal interactions are like
that's just everyone but
when i encounter people who i would find
[Music]
teeter being extremists um
on the left or right and i see
how they're only
being this way or holding these weapons
because they assume
the other side wants revenge or they
assume
an overwhelming amount of people on that
side
wants to get them really that there are
people that do
but majority of people
i don't feel like they do that is okay
so you've now
surprised me quite a bit here i think
maybe similarly to
my surprising you with respect to what
gets said
when a black person leaves the room but
my
sense is that we are i feel like i'm
watching
a revolution in which every institution
that i know of is being transformed and
they're adopting
not only beliefs but policy that i know
just can't be made to work right
just simply will not work it's going to
result in all of these institutions
falling apart and failing to do what
they need to do
which uh in some cases will be very sad
and in other cases will be a catastrophe
but um the idea that most of the
people who are part of the movement that
is driving this
might be exhausted and interested
in putting their weapons down i don't
know
i don't know how that deal gets brokered
but wow would it be smart for us to
figure it out because
you know this is going to be a short
ride if this revolution
wins it's going to destroy the stuff
that makes
us strong and then it doesn't matter how
the pie gets divided it's not going to
be much pie
you know yeah and i do want to be clear
i
i guess i don't know if i heard the full
question of what you asked
definitely different between
interpersonal relationships or
conversation
happening with me and like institutions
and universities like it's that's a
different story and i feel like these
kids
are just echo chambers of what their
professors are saying and they don't
even know what they believe
but um yes i do think
though even even them
there they might just feel like this is
the way i show that
i'm a part of this movement and that i
want change
and but there's been so many people who
have walked away from being a liberal
because they're just like one they see
that it's counterproductive and
the whole ideology backfires on itself
and they say it was exhausting to go
into every single room
all the time and having to like detect
if
this is racist this is sexist is this
stuff like
they were like and often times i was
actually creating it in my head
and it wasn't there at all um
and then you could look on the other
side uh
and i'll just use this man as an example
dale davis
you know befriending ku klux klaners
not just people that voted for someone
that people might not like
ku klux klaners who say they hate people
who look just like him
where his friendship has
you know allowed them i guess in a way
to 200 to 300 of them
to leave willingly not that he said
you know if you if we're friends you
can't be in this no he would go there
because he knew what he was doing and he
knew it was kind of like
a strategic move of love on his part
and that's what i mean the weapons like
people don't
at the end of the day those men
when i listened to the podcast and i
actually saw him in person at nyu and i
and he was with the former ku klux
klaner who talked about
how my hate had nothing to do with black
people it had everything to do with the
fact
i hated myself and he said the majority
of people in these
movements ku klux klaners are usually
boys that don't have a father figure
who's looking for community
who is looking for a place of love he's
like
it's almost in the same contrast as
maybe an inner city kid
looking for love with a gang he said
it's just like we're looking for
something and instead of doing internal
work on ourselves we project it on
something and that's easy to project it
on black people and if
i have to do that to have kinship with
these people i'm going to do that
and so when you hear these stories time
and
time again on other sides for me i've
come to the conclusion
people are are exhausted but they just
don't trust
the other side and
and don't want to be vulnerable for the
other side
but who who goes first is the question
well so interestingly daryl davis is as
an example
if i think back i've heard many many
conversations
about him in many different racial
contexts i've never heard
anyone say anything negative right
everybody likes the story
right and it's a it's a surprising
interesting
wonderful story and you know it does it
does say all kinds of things you know i
i understand the impulse to do what he
did i have that same
impulse i would not have thought it
would work at the level
that he made it work it's it's a
marvelous testament to
his insight into the situation and his
courage to do it
because you know the instinct to do it
is one thing the
actually taking the risk of doing it is
quite another
but in any case i think again you you
know i'm still a little bit surprised by
your sense that uh at least
interpersonally
people are interested in escaping this
dynamic
right i see it accelerating but if
people really wanted it
to be stood down
that would be very very healthy um
now as for you know i think you're
pointing to exactly the
obstacle that will prevent it from
happening which is somebody has to go
first and at this moment that's a very
vulnerable thing to do
on either side but
oh there there's got to be a way and you
know i
increasingly think it's probably going
to have to do
with modeling difficult conversations
so that people understand what that
would look like in other words
if we could illustrate the standing down
of the
tension between individuals where the
tension existed
then there's a lot of room for other
people to
to follow suit 100 and that's why
um i do engage in conversations with
people
one i and i the first public
like person that i think was kind of you
know well-known
benjamin boyce i i had a conversation
with him in september
after my article came out in talent
magazine
free black thought and one i had the
conversation because
i think it was needed at that time
and two i knew his base would not ever
search for me
they would not know my name even if
people over here might know me
i might not be in their algorithm ever
and i
i felt like i was not walking to the
lion's den but i didn't
i was talking about black lives matter
and i know how his base feels about it
but i felt like
if i can humanize this in a way where
the weapons are down in this
conversation with
benjamin and we're having an organic
conversation authentic
and they can see into why
someone would do a blm what's the
purpose
what's why would they want to be on this
mission
and just humanize their sentiments
i was like it's worth a shot and i was
shocked by the reception
it was funny because a lot of the
comments
and then people will come on my channel
and and give comments
and these come scratch subscribers and
it wasn't because they agreed with me at
all
i mean they made it very clear i don't
agree with blm
i don't agree with the fact that you
were willing to have this conversation
and that you're willing to listen and
that i actually did gain
some knowledge into something i never
would have considered
that was a win i was like
this is okay this is what i'm going to
continue to do
and i've gotten a lot of comments now
with my channel where
people are speaking up and i'm not going
to say there's hundreds but i've gotten
at least 15 comments from
white black men and women
and other and hispanic and asian people
talking about you know
i have to do this diversity uh training
or this inclusion training
and i wouldn't cr i what i told people
is i encourage you to participate and
raise the issues
while you're doing it in good faith like
don't just be like i don't want to do
this
but raise it when you're doing it so
they see that you're actually
trying and that you're now questioning
like
well this actually i see a flaw here
like can we discuss it like discuss it
when you're there with them
um because they're not not gonna hear it
if you are just
you know but and then there's a lot of
people are like these are the thoughts
i've had
a lot of black people they're like this
is the thoughts i've had
they're like i agree with the sentiment
of black lives matter black lives matter
but i also have these issues and now
and now i'm voicing them like stuff like
that is enough
for me um and then also
with with white people saying they're
willing to be more open
to to hearing other people's point of
view um and voicing their own point of
view
and feeling like okay now i know how to
actually shape my conversation where
someone's not thinking i'm trying to
attack them like that's enough
and i think that is what more people
need to do
but it's not easy at all
it's being made more difficult because
you mentioned
benjamin i don't know if you know
benjamin's a good friend of mine
um but he is portrayed
as i am actually as being somehow
on the right and sometimes or even
portrayed as far right
or alt-right and there is actually zero
to it
it's just simply not accurate and so the
problem with that is on the one hand yes
it's very annoying to be
dismissed and portrayed this way but the
worse
effect and i think the reason that it
happens is because there is a desire to
keep the very people who need to hear it
from hearing it so if you are on the
left trying to figure out what to make
of
things at the moment then you're very
unlikely to end up
going to listen to a channel that you've
heard is far right
alt-right whatever right right so the
point is
it that stigma means that the number of
people who saw
your interaction was less than it might
have been
and that means that it can't do as much
good as it needs to do
which you know frankly if you take
people like you or benjamin
and you put them in these conversations
of course it will do good
right these are these are model
individuals who are capable of having a
model conversation
the problems aren't zero but they're
solvable and the
way to solve them is for people who
don't know
you know the details of what's on the
other side of the conversation to
discover it together and for
the audience to come along so you know i
i don't know what percentage of the
problem
has to do with uh people
being driven away from channels that are
the ones they most need to hear but i
think it's significant
[Music]
you